Buonasera a tutti Grazie per questo
onore per me davvero un grande onore
essere qua con voi
porto un tema che nessuno vuole
ascoltare porto in te ma già prima di
iniziare e sentire con le reazioni
chimica già dice ma queste cose si
vogliono raccontare Ma cosa vuole qua
quindi non è facile per me Io
sono eritreo quasi un gran parte
italiano non stanno neanche dove Eritrea
di qui Siete state a casa mia per oltre
50 anni a casa mia un paese molto bello
sta sul Mare Rosso ancora a casa mia
tipo in capitale il nostro bisnonni
parlo italiano abbiamo anche le scuole
italiane Ma se tu vai in giro di Siri 3
ma insomma ogni ritraccia ti cominciano
no a dirti ma Africa Ma tipo dove Ah
siano e fa capire
quanto a volte abbiamo
storia Corte come visto davvero un paese
bellissimo però è diventato un paese di
sofferenza in sofferenza sofferenza per
tanti giovani come me se io oggi qua
sono con voi va a mia madre che ha
rischiato che ha sacrificato per la sua
vita e per darmi un futuro migliore io
dicevo da piccolo era un ragazzino bravo
in chimica in matematica In fisica il
mio sogno è di diventare pilota ma
invece oggi faccio una cosa che non ho
mai scelto di parlare di immigrazione di
donne di uomini di violenza eccetera
eccetera e quindi
perché spesso
qui in Italia non sanno qual è il motivo
così forte spingi queste persone
rischiare così forte è vero siamo Tutti
bravissimi e conosciamo l'Ucraina
addirittura Siamo disposti a dare mille
cose ma invece quelle persone non
sappiamo Perché una persona
disposta a morire per arrivare qua e
quindi se io oggi qua mia madre in certi
punti ha perso il marito il mio fratello
grande che io ancora Ragazzi avevo 16
anni ha cercato di farmi uscire fuori
quel paese quando siamo uscire non vuol
dire io ormai al mese faccio quasi 20
voli aerei da una parte al sud a nord da
tutti parte al mondo lì Ci vogliono
circa 8-9 mesi per poter preparare la
fuga perché
perché se ti fermano in confine lo Stato
Cosa fa a volte ti uccide per dare un
segnale
se Qual è il tuo Se tu pensi tentare di
uscire quali sono le conseguenze o sono
l'alternativa ti mandano questi carceri
dell'isola
bellissima quasi in Paradiso che
all'epoca lo usava Mussolini come
carcere ancora oggi sono attivi e quindi
ti portavano in queste strutture che
rimane a vita non sono familiare può
venire a visitarti non puoi avere anche
il diritto di difenderti Se tu esci dal
paese tipo come oggi Sono cittadino
italiano o il mio passaporti europeo ma
non posso andare a casa mia perché
essendo attraversato il confine
o commesso un reato molto grave quindi è
per tutta la mia vita finché il mio
ultimo respiro non può tornare la mia
casa e profumi il cibo tutti che Dove è
nato Non posso più tornare come se fosse
ti tolgono le tue radici per sempre
quando siamo scappare
una volta attraverso quel confine sai
quale Con la conseguenza sai il
99%
stai andando ad affrontare una morte
certa hai una possibilità di poter
raggiungere le ultime destinazioni
se dici
di origine di quel 10 solo due o tre
riescono a arrivare all'ultima tappa
spesso sento tutti i leader dicono
brutti Cattivi questo straficanti è vero
però per noi è l'unica alternativa non
sai a chi affidarti non sai chi a
chiedere aiuto perché sei tu il tuo Dio
non c'è un altro e quindi un ragazzo
come vedi almeno ci provo
se va storto è andata così se riesco
almeno ho raggiunto l'altra parte sono
Dopo lungo viaggio Ho impiegato quasi
circa 4 anni
con le cose che mi fa sentire in colpa a
un certo punto metà viaggio mia mamma
con un bel sorriso
mi trova tre caramelle cominciava a
sorridere come se fosse immaginato tua
madre se mette le bombacchieve comincia
a sorridere come fosse ha vinto milioni
di euro cominciamo a sorridere io to mia
mamma Ormai è andato fuori testa c'è
qualcosa non andava ho preso qualcosa o
andato fuori testa e un contest per una
donna in un paese non sei irregolare
Perché non si può dire che clandestino
se avete un reato era Un clandestino
perché anche utilizziamo il clandestino
ormai come le caramelle e quindi poteva
sorridere mi tiravo tre caramelle
accendevo un incenzio una candela
dicevatarè che ci dobbiamo separare vi
assicuro avete del Sud No siamo molto
legata alla famiglia io volevo morire
perché da quanto sono nato non sono mai
separato mia madre separare vuol dire
per me morire
lei era ferma non non si spostava
neanche un sentiero mi dice tiene queste
caramelle Io sono sicuro andrà tutto
bene se riesce a arrivare dall'altra
parte mi verrà a prendere
è molto arrabbiato con mia madre perché
sapeva forse saremo visti per l'ultima
volta sapeva consigliava un figlio una
morte certa però sapeva anche la
possibilità con quel poco soldi solo uno
poteva andare avanti Quindi lei come se
fosse ha pronunciato per vivere quel
poco mi ha regalato a me che anche oggi
ancora soffrisco di quella sua
opportunità Insomma è tempo corre e così
è stato un viaggio molto lunghissimo ho
stato respinto varie volte e tutti i
carsellini più di quella che voi
immaginate che ho subito visto gente che
morire dentro subiva di tutto arrivo in
Italia il mio primo giorno mi veniva
assegnato un numero io il numero era
1883 io oggi ho musei importanti il
primo in Italia
inaugurato pubblica sono da prendere
gli esperti di italiani quando andavo in
America che veniva utilizzato le stesse
emergenze Voi andate a vedere i reperti
o le fotografie quando andavo in America
ciascun italiano aveva un numero aveva
una grande lavagna come vedete qui un
numero xxx e quindi lo cerca di mettere
i reperti di ieri oggi vi assicuro si fa
fatica a identificare quale oggi quale
di ieri e così giravo l'Italia
conoscevo delle persone che diventano
famiglie che lavorano nelle campagne
della mattinata sicuramente dopo essere
la campagna sotto pagati della mattina a
sera con 20 €10 Però hanno cose che voi
non avete
hanno un sorriso Sono felici di essere
vivi c'è già respirano per loro è una
cosa enorme No perché noi Ormai oggi
conoscere i soldi l'amore macchina
vogliamo vogliamo ma non apprezziamo mai
le cose che noi abbiamo uno non dice mai
Grazie che io ho una famiglia un tetto
posso o il frigo pieno siamo sempre lì
vogliamo Anzi siamo invidiosi degli
altri che ha di più e che non siamo
disposti a condividere le cose che non
abbiamo e così
girato in Italia Questo è il museo che
sta a Lampedusa che mi avete preso
Repubblica e così nel
2000 nel 2013
nel 2013 ci sono questi bar davanti uno
delle spiagge più importanti d'Italia
anche di Europa davanti di conigli
morirono
368 persone
su 500 persone sono sopravvissuti 155
solo 5 donne il resto di tutti uomini
tutti i bambini e le donne sono tutti
quasi morti Addirittura C'è una donna
incinta partorito dentro l'acqua mentre
moriva ancora era collegato il cordone
ombelicale e questo invece Dieci anni
dopo e questo contro come se fosse in
dieci anni sette governi ancora oggi per
l'indifferenza sono morti circa
27.000 persone ancora oggi nessuno tenta
dare risposte ancora oggi io per prima
lottiamo per dare un'identità a quelle
persone spesso Voi sapete quasi non
sappiamo quando viene trovato un
cadavere
non bene a identificato chiamano portano
le barre mettono le barre sigla Non mi
mettere senza cimitero sei all'indomani
Io voglio cercare Mio figlio è
impossibile ma neanche per prendere la
Repubblica ti può dire forse potrebbe
essere mio figlio per identificare
eccetera eccetera sapete perché
importanti identificare perché ci ha
capitato sono dei figli perché usate
l'enormità europea che perdono la mamma
o la patria per avere il passaporto e
per avere qualunque atto amministrativo
serve la firma di due genitori o se no
un documento che accompagna una
motivarlo per perché non mancava quando
non hai il corpo che non puoi provare
che è morto in conseguenza
è impossibile quindi il figlio diventa
vittime due volte da una parte della
madre e la madre dall'altra parte
non può andare avanti finché non compie
18 anni che ancora oggi noi abbiamo
tutti i nostri cimiteri ancora non
vengono identificate però se io trovo un
corpo per la strada per l'estrazione ci
sono di protocollo attivo il processo
scientifico foto frigo rimango finché
XXI tempo per essere identificate però
ancora oggi anche da morti queste
persone non hanno la possibilità di
essere identificati Questo è un po'
lavoro abbiamo fatto a Sciacca a volte
in alcuni comuni per chi il comune
sapete se io metto una barra la legge
italiana dice per 99 per 99 anni queste
barre non viene spostata ma invece
spesso in alcuni comune quando sei
immigrati fanno delle Fosse comune
esposte perché sapete il posto costa
voglio dare stendini spesso vengono
fatti di questi fosse comune un esempio
Sciacca
Somma
siamo riusciti sono riuscita a portare
una proposta di legge il Parlamento
italiano è stata approvata nel 2016
diventata la giornata della memoria
della quiesa per tutti le vittime del
Mediterraneo perché noi abbiamo detto
almeno una volta all'anno vogliamo
ricordare queste persone
essere vicini perché sono persone
nate invisibili
non sarà mai chi sono queste persone
sono persone vittime del loro governi
vittime della politica internazionale
Europea eccetera eccetera
di comune di dedicare un spazio a queste
persone siamo riusciti anche in tanti
comuni questo non solo
girando per l'Italia sentire spesso
rifiutato o Niente paura come se fosse
una specie viene da martedì Ieri io
andavo al ristorante qua entro
vedevo niente mi guardavano un po'
strano sembra tipo una specie ha
cominciato a ridere a commentare
Telespalla Bob sono fuori dal tonno io
Mantengo la calma cercavo di respirare e
cercando di non raggire con loro e
cercare sempre la via del dialogo che a
oggi impossibile trovare via del dialogo
e sento anche spesso italiani prima
italiani ho conosciuto italiani che
nascono crescono senza conoscere
l'Italia parola delle Fragole Io non so
quanti italiano sono
coltivano le fragole sapendo in Italia
italiani non partiteva Da Bolzano ci
sono in italiano parlano anche italiano
e così lavorando con i ragazzi perché la
mia idea voglio salvare il domani iodio
verso le strade di oggi di oggi quindi
facendo un lavoro enorme giro l'Italia e
l'Europa cercano di creare una rete di
scuole di ragazzi giovani per la prima
volta nelle storie europee sono riuscita
a mettere i ragazzi di 26 paesi europea
di 20 regioni che ogni anno vanno
Lampedusa è vero sono cambiati tra uno e
l'altro si incontrano però mai successo
di ragazzi di 20 paesi europei è vero
anche principesse
purtroppo non funziona colpa di francese
ma noi sappiamo un francese un tedesco
un rumeno un polacco come vive come
mangia come pensa non lo sappiamo però
siamo i primi a commentare oggi se non
funziona senza conoscere il mio
Nazionale perché l'Europa e siamo unico
Grazie anche l'Europa abbiamo invitato
tanti guerra che grazie ai vostri nonni
e così ho creato una rete talmente forte
che oggi Grazie a loro che andiamo
avanti che ogni anno che vengono
quest'anno anche Saranno nel decennale a
Lampedusa eccetera eccetera
e queste qui vedete che ogni anno che
vengono a tutte l'Europa da tutti
l'Italia di cui la vostra scuola che
anche gli anni presidente hanno
partecipato da tutti questi ragazzi e
vederli molto bello fare anche conoscere
il ragazzo Spagna di Favara di Agrigento
di Palermo eccetera eccetera vado veloci
perché il tempo corre è se io dico ma
chitarre che numero 183 Oggi cosa fa
seguendo la trasmissione
parecchio il papa Mattarella tratta col
Governo dico se una persona messa in
condizione può dare di più di quelle che
riceve anche oggi Sono cittadino
passaporto ancora il New York delle
persone sono quelle Poverino quella
sfigato
ora sull'autobus Quando vai a comprare
nei negozi ti guardano un po' stranito
però devi cercare fare spiegare sono
persone come tutti gli altri vivo bianco
soffro come tutti gli altri
e quindi
ancora oggi ci penso tantissimo la mia
foto prima
1883 ma dicono ma chi è spesso ci penso
però non solo non so che cos'è registra
Garrone Mattel Garrone il 7 uscirà
il film Il fatto da lui di qui una parte
di mia storia di cui resta da qui andrò
per anche camminare sul tappeto rosso al
cinema
e quindi il mio invito è importante da
una parte
apprezzate cose che voi avete Eh ragazzi
non si può dire ho sentito dire
[Musica]
si può io per poter giudicare una
persona in un posto scritto italiano se
non mafiosi camorrista gente combatte la
mafia c'è gente che vive con la scorta
c'è gente che si ribella questa non si
può un reato quando ho fatto da una
persona
bene tu un megafono viene aumentato in
marea costante se lo assostreato fatto
da uno cittadino Allora giusto come
diceva prima si va a giustificare e
girare intorno Ma ma quello che sei Non
solo e spesso ha un eritreo ha un
nitigliano
nome e cognome con le persone Quindi
grazie Mi sono già superato il mio tempo
scusa e ancora Davvero grazie grazie
grazie
[Applauso]